problema número 55 sigue es igual a 4
más x menos 3 al cuadrado ya está en su
menor valor cuando x es entonces
encontraremos el menor valor posible de
4 más x menos 3 al cuadrado y
concentrémonos en ese término x menos 3
al cuadrado pues porque es el único que
tiene la x el que puede variar cualquier
número real al cuadrado va a darnos un
número positivo así que este término
será mayor o igual a 0
pero sería el menor valor posible de
este término para que esto sea cero para
que x 360 x debe ser igual a 3 así que
ya tiene su menor valor cuando x es
igual a 3 que es nuestra opción de
pasemos al siguiente problema número 56
cuál de los siguientes no es igual al
cuadrado de un entero y tenemos todas
estas opciones vamos a analizar una por
una
veamos la opción número uno raíz
cuadrada de raíz cuadrada de 1 esto va a
ser igual a 1 y 1 es igual a 1 al
cuadrado así que esta opción no es
segunda opción ok
raíz cuadrada de 4 esto es igual a 2
este 2 es igual a raíz de 2 al cuadrado
sin embargo esto esto de aquí no es un
entero así que esta es nuestra opción
correcta vemos la siguiente 10 y 83 18
entre 3 va a ser igual a 9 y 9 es el
cuadrado de 33 por 39
41 menos 25 es igual a 16 y 16 es el
cuadrado de 4 así que confirmamos
nuestra selección de que la respuesta
correcta es esta opción siguiente
problema número 57 un número primo de
fermat es un número primo que puede
escribirse con el formato 2 a la cara
más uno donde k es un entero y una
potencia de 2 cuál de los siguientes no
es un número primo de fermat analicemos
cada una de estas opciones
lo puedo descomponer como 2 a la 1 + 11
es potencia de 22 a la ser es igual a 1
así que esta opción no es la siguiente 5
es igual lo puedes componer como 2 a 2
más 12 a las 12 4 1 5 y 2 es potencia de
2 2 a la 1 es igual a 2
puedo descomponerlo como 2 a la 4 1
no hay un número dos alacrán en los de
30 entonces para 31
no hay un número que pueda yo elevar el
2 que me dé 30 porque no se agrega un 1
para tener 31 tendría que tener 2 algo
igual a 30 y esto no se cumple así que
nuestra respuesta es nuestra opción de
él no puede ser porque 257 es igual a
257 es igual a 2 a la 8 más 1 2 al 8 de
256 más 1 pues es igual a 257 veamos el
siguiente problema problema número 58 si
x cuadrado es igual a 2 y a la 3 y 2 y
es igual a 4 aquí sigue igual x cuadrada
más o que entonces nos están dando que x
cuadrada es igual a 2 que kubica
22 es igual a 4 y nos preguntan a que es
igual x cuadrado más y vamos a sustituir
esto de x cuadrado igualados al cubo acá
entonces esto es 2 al cubo más
y nos dicen que 2 es igual a 4 así que
estas 10 si no es igual a 4 de solita va
a ser igual a 2 sustituimos aquí lo
sustituimos aquí 2 por 2 al cubo más 2
esto es igual a 2 al cubo es 8 por 2 16
2 es igual a 18 y 18 es nuestra opción
ay qué tan extraña bueno es una el
siguiente problema número 59 una
solución de glucosa contiene 15 gramos
de glucosa por 100 centímetros cúbicos
de solución sin 45 centímetros cúbicos
de la solución se vierten en un
contenedor vacío cuántos gramos de
glucosa habrá en el contenedor vamos a
hacer la operación nos dicen que hay 15
gramos de glucosa en
100 centímetros cúbicos de solución y
esto nos preguntan a qué es igual en
gramos
si tenemos 45 centímetros cúbicos de
solución pues podemos hacer una
multiplicación cruzada aquí voy a tener
15 por 45 igual a x por 100 y para
facilitar los cálculos y miramos a ambos
lados entre 5 este 45 entre 5 es 9 este
100 entre 5 va a ser 20 y esto lo
podemos dividir de nuevo entre 5 y 15 en
35 va a ser igual a 3
y 20 entre 5 a ser igual a 4 así que voy
a tener 9 por 3 27 igual a x por 44 x
despejó x x es igual a 27 entre 4 que
esto es igual a 6
tres cuartos y esto es igual a 6.75 que
es nuestra opción en este me quedo mejor
veamos el último problema del servidor
problema el número sesenta nos dan esta
figura y nos preguntan de esta figura
cuánto es de menos x así que tenemos que
encontrar el valor de xy el valor de g y
estos pues son ángulos bueno ya que esto
es un paralelogramo sabemos qué
esta línea de acá es paralela con esta
línea de acá y también sabemos que esta
línea de acá es paralela a esta línea de
acá nos da mucha información en especial
si extendemos estas líneas de aquí y de
aquí las extiendo esta década ésta
también
está
a lo mejor estás trato de escribir mejor
porque no se ven paralelas
esta siesta mejor está la extendemos sí
y esta de acá también muy bien ya con
estas líneas comenzaremos a recordar lo
visto en geometría acerca de las líneas
paralelas
estas dos líneas de acá esta línea de
acá y esta línea de acá son paralelas
podemos ver a esta línea como una
transversal y aquí nos dan el ángulo 140
grados
dos serán ángulos correspondientes es
decir son iguales entre sí con esto nos
dicen que 140 es igual a 2 para conocer
el valor de g
dividido todo entre 2
y es igual a 140 entre 2 es igual a 70
entonces aquí
es igual a 70 y este ángulo este de acá
sigue siendo 140 ok considerando que
estas líneas de acá arriba está
y esta línea de acá
son paralelas podemos ver esta línea de
acá como una transversal entonces estos
140 grados de aquí y este otro ángulo de
acá de acá van a ser iguales así que
aquí también voy a tener 140 grados y
este ángulo que acabo de dibujar será
suplementario del ángulo x es decir que
la suma de este ángulo con este otro
ángulo van a dar 180 grados
por lo tanto x más 140 que es el ángulo
que acabo de encontrar acá deben ser
igual a 180 para que eso se cumpla x
debe ser igual a 40 y ahora ya conocemos
xy entonces lo que nos preguntan de
cuánto es menos x 1070
x es 40 70 menos 40 es igual a 30
es nuestra opción y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo